non et c'est comme les frites c'est
quand on re bonjour c'est nous les tuons
prêtre d'après on est de retour à bout
ce grand vos yeux il exactement
c'est le moment de préparer noël en
famille mois ce qui se passe quand je
cours et je voudrais que ma soeur soit
il a aussi problème c'est son mari se
khodjali oui oui ça va vous êtes
chamailler là tous les deux là pour des
conneries il ya dix ans alors au marteau
tu as toujours travaillé je me régale
ses magazines magiquement une pizza chez
bata animaux jamais livrer une pizza au
fromage pas de pizza trois fromages deux
fois trop ça fait suer trop vu leurs
amis vos chine contre l'ennemi
qu'est ce que je disais déjà le vent lui
coûtait pas aller voir lui si tu perds
d'oreille
il a pu désigner jouer je wanda qui
m'agace zone mark maigrot gagne les
petits meurent vous êtes dans la
deuxième catégorie désolé je ne
proposition à vous faire et voilà mon
plan racheter limacher et fabriquer des
jouets hambourg quand tu vois retour que
des clous et fabrique un jouet que nous
n'avons pas vous pourriez appeler
l'inspection du travail
il avait travaillé mais sais tu ce nom
je ne travaille pas je suis pas trop
vous a déjà vu un patron qui travaillent
vous non
c'est les échos je connais tu connais tu
connais ouais de quoi de quoi à ok j'y
suis les efforts très drôle très drôle
[Musique]
et anne parfois les apparences sont
trompeuses
il faudra que tu regardes bien au delà
te projeter beaucoup plus loin ça va
être douloureux demont veut pas et anne
ça t'aidera accomplir son destin
les faits ne cesse de croître en raison
des rejets biophysique de l'oxygène
artificielle appelée plus communément le
mal du siècle
l'année dernière j'avais vingt gamins
dans ma classe cette année j'en ai tous
et and white
vous savez ce que votre père a failli si
je vous présente le chronicle si je vous
disais que vous avez la possibilité de
tous nous sauver
sauvez votre femme nous avons reçu un
message qui venait du futur du futur
c'est une machine à voyager dans le
temps ceux qui ont envoyé ce message ont
dû trouver un remède
tu crois vraiment que je vais sauver le
monde ton peur y croyait vous êtes
peut-être la seule chance qu'il reste à
l'humanité de trouver un axe à 9
8 sec
ouah
ethan de revient
nous devons trouver ceux qui ont envoyé
ce message nous sommes une collision
d'un voyage qui pourrait tout changer
il faut que je fasse confiance il ne
s'agit plus de trouver un remède il ya
certainement quelque chose qui nous
échappe
imagine que nous sommes tous
physiquement relié à l'univers il ya un
champ invisible qui nous lie les uns aux
autres toi moi les étoiles ne vaut rien
sans ses petits doigts se passer se
passa ya pas d'autres moyens
nous sommes tous connectés à travers le
temps il s'agit pas de sauver le mandat
la maturité
son mari
[Musique]
non c'est moi
dans la rue
à quelques pas
le projet de zone et n'estime pas que
puissant
[Musique]
on y voit des femmes
m
[Musique]
grossmann
vous arrête
pour déjouer
[Musique]
un gain
oui coping with you pay what
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lacroix radio
oui
[Musique]
et
tous
[Musique]
toi
m
et sinon
[Musique]
caracas
elle a vécu
famille
[Musique]
moi
voilà
tu es
ghani baradar
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
k
tél